c'est ce que disait françois bayrou si
on pense tous pareils c'est qu'on a fini
de panser
donc il ya 10 ans us il y as démocratie
et nous nous sommes dans une réflexion
ou le 10 ans us se gère sans se taper
dessus d'une part et se gère sans que
j'en ai un qui décide pour tous les
autres que vérifie ce texte par exemple
première chose qu'ils vérifient que
vérifier la commission dans chaque pays
c'est la séparation des pouvoirs
c'est fondamental quand en face de notre
ministre monsieur ghosn qui s'adressait
à la représentante de la révolte des
femmes en pologne elle a dit mais vous
savez si vous voulez nous aider
donnez nous la séparation des pouvoirs
donnés nous là le l'état de droit après
nous les femmes on s'en occupe et les
femmes polonaises faites nous confiance
on est tout à fait capable de s'occuper
de nous mêmes l'histoire et ses
mentalités peuvent rester différent je
conçois tout à fait que vivre en pologne
le rapport à la nation le rapport à
l'histoire le rapport à le rapport à la
religion
le rapport à l'histoire européenne en
hongrie par exemple va être différent
pendant de longues générations de la
même manière qu'il est différent en ce
moment entre un breton et un corps ça
c'est pas un problème ça ce qui est un
problème c'est ce que nous devons avoir
en commun et qui poseraient problème si
ça n'était pas respectée c'est un socle
de manière de gérer nos 10 ans us qui
doit être le même en terme de territoire
en terme d'organisation des pouvoirs
ça ça doit être le même au bélarus
qu'est-ce qui se passe en 92 et élu
quelqu'un contre la mafia loukachenko
qui se présente qui était lui à la
démocratique et qui est toujours là et
qui petit à petit a mal tourné est
devenu un pouvoir extrêmement
autoritaire avant les élections de l'an
dernier il y avait des opposants qui
s'était mis moderniser et qui s'était
mis à le menacer grandement parce qu'ils
étaient épuisés
de plus en plus difficile de cacher le
fait qu'il n'avait plus le soutien de
son peuple
il y à ce problème aujourd'hui avec des
prisons violente des prisons où il ya
manifestement des gens qui disparaissent
il ya des gens qui sont dues
disparu on le sait ce qui se passe au
bélarus aujourd'hui ça nous concerne pas
comme ce qui nous coûte pas comme ce qui
se passe à varsovie pas comme ce qui se
passe à bucarest mais ça nous concerne
parce que c'est notre voisin
il faut que dans notre voisin proche
d'entre nous au voisinage proche nous
ayons des rapports apaisés nous ayons
des rapports de confiance qu aujourd'hui
nous ne pouvons pas avoir et ça c'est
notre problème c'est notre problème ce
qui se passe en ce moment là bas nous ne
pouvons pas l'admettre pas uniquement
pour des raisons humanitaires comme
l'inde mettons nulle part ailleurs dans
le monde mais également pour des raisons
d'intérêt de protection si la maison de
votre voisin brûle c'est pas pareil que
quand la maison brûle de l'autre côté de
la ville